what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have a lot
of Marvel news to go over some good and
some well not necessarily bad but let's
just say that there are some change-ups
happening with blade but like I said
there is still a lot of good happening
Hugh Jackman has begun training to be
Wolverine once again and it looks like
Harrison Ford the man the myth the
legend could be joining the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this would be
absolutely legendary and of course we'll
talk about this report in detail but
keep in mind of course he's with Star
Wars which is owned by Disney and then
Indiana Jones which is lucasfilm which
again is owned by Disney and of course
Disney owns Marvel Studios so big
connections there to the MCU if Harrison
Ford wants to be in the MCU and there is
a role for him I'm pretty sure that
would be a done deal and it looks like
they might have found a pretty dang good
role so like I said lots to jump into
two in this video let's get started but
of course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news also if you want
to keep up to date with other things not
in the MCU you can follow my other
channel Cosmic entertainment we talk
about a lot of stuff over there
including DC Star Wars Planet of the
Apes you name it I'll link that up top
and put it down below in the description
and pin comment as well so of course the
most exciting news that we got this week
was Ryan Reynolds announcing that
Deadpool 3 was on his way giving us an
official release date of September 6th
of 2024 but most importantly announcing
that Hugh Jackman is going to be
returning as Wolverine they give us a
little video teaser then they gave us
another teaser the very next day with
Hugh Jackman in it talking with Ryan
Reynolds about how he's going to be
returning and not offsetting his death
in Logan but that the movie is going to
be awesome and based off of what they
said or kind of teased us with there's
going to be a lot of fighting and we
actually have had some details about
Deadpool 3 emerge since this
announcement the biggest report right
now is coming from Daniel rpk via his
patreon a lot of people know Daniel rpk
by now but if you don't he's an Insider
who has a good track record of getting
things right for Scoops and he is saying
right now the current plan for Hugh
Jackman is to wear the yellow Wolverine
suit in Deadpool 3. we saw this suit
teased in the Wolverine Hugh Jackman
opened up a case that had the classic
yellow suit in it and according to
Daniel rpk that is what we are going to
see him wear in Deadpool 3 which I'm
really excited for a classic comic
accurate Wolverine yellow costume that's
gonna be a lot of fun and I'm pretty
sure Deadpool is gonna make fun of it
which is going to be even more fun now
something that is very interesting that
has happened today is that there's been
a new report that is not confirmed that
you should take with a grain of salt
that says Deadpool 4 is already
confirmed this report is coming from
giant freaking robot their track record
is kind of spotty they've been right but
they've also been wrong so take with a
grain of salt but it does make sense
that Deadpool 4 would already be
confirmed Ryan Reynolds is over at
Marvel Studios now the Deadpool
franchise has been extremely successful
and they've had a low budget so far when
they were with fox now they're at Marvel
Studios with a bigger budget no doubt
that they're going to want to go for
more than just Deadpool 3. I would be
shocked if we didn't get a Deadpool 4
and I'm assuming Deadpool is going to
pop up randomly in the MCU and other
projects as well so this report isn't
that big of a surprise now Hugh Jackman
has posted to his Instagram that he has
begun getting in Wolverine's shape of
course Hugh Jackman is known for being
absolutely shredded as Wolverine and
obviously it's really really hard to
stay in that shape just all of the time
every day out of the Year Andy hasn't
played Wolverine in some time now so
he's getting back in shape he posted
this to Instagram also somebody posted a
tick tock of him just walking on the
street being really excited about
playing Wolverine again here it is and
full credits to The Tick Tock account
uncrazed for posting this you can follow
them on tick tock
[Music]
I know I know how you doing how's
everything all good man yeah all good
inside I can't wait I can't wait to see
you in that big screen again always good
to see you all right brother
Logan's back Wolverine
so things are getting super super
exciting with the MCU right now with
Deadpool 3 having Hugh Jackman return as
Wolverine and of course Deadpool in
general is super exciting as well so now
let's move on to the Harrison Ford
report the recent report is that
Harrison Ford has met with Marvel
Studios to talk about an upcoming role
and that he could be replacing William
Hurt as Thunderbolt Ross and I gotta
tell you I actually really really like
this I love Harrison Ford of course he
is classic he's iconic and like I
mentioned before he is close with Disney
now this report is coming from Jeff
Snyder he's a reporter for the ankler
and also a film critic as well he has
claimed that Harrison Ford is the top
Contender the Top Choice by Marvel
Studios for who they want to play
Thunderbolt Ross now for those who may
not be familiar with the situation sadly
and very very unfortunately William Hurt
passed away way he passed away earlier
this year in March he had a great career
and was known for many roles but of
course in the MCU he played Thunderbolt
Ross and for a while we didn't know if
they were going to recast his character
or put that character to the side
however at sdcc they announced the
Thunderbolts movie and if you're not
aware the Thunderbolts are named after
Thunderbolt Ross so of course after that
was announced a lot of us thought well
they have to continue the character
Thunderbolt Ross if the Thunderbolts are
going to exist either that or they're
just going to make the name have nothing
to do with Thunderbolt Ross and that has
happened in the comics there have been
Thunderbolts team where Thunderbolt Ross
and red Hulk were not a part of but this
new report is very very interesting
because I think Harrison Ford would do
an amazing job and I would love to have
him in the MCU now they could also take
this a different way since William Hurt
passed away in real life they could
actually have his character pass away in
the MCU and they could simply state that
they named their team the Thunderbolts 2
on honor Thunderbolt Ross after all
Harrison Ford is a little bit older now
he is 80 years old however he did just
do Indiana Jones 5. so he's still very
much active and according to this report
Marvel Studios was actually planning on
announcing that Harrison Ford would be
Thunderbolt Ross at d23 however since
they were talking about Indiana Jones as
well and he came out for that they
didn't want that to overshadow any
announcement for Indiana Jones 5. we'll
have to wait and see on that in the
meantime let me know your thoughts about
Harrison Ford playing Thunderbolt Ross
in the comments down below and now we'll
move on to Blade we have some news now
if you haven't been keeping up all you
basically need to know is that blade
lost its director the reason stated was
because of some scheduling conflicts
however recent reports and rumors have
come out that stated that he was
actually fired now that is not confirmed
that is just what people are saying
especially after mahershala Ali who was
going to be playing blade came out and
said that the script was only 90 pages
long it only had 2 fight scenes and they
weren't very good and he expressed much
frustration with the project and the
script so far well today we have great
news for him and great news for us as
well the blade script is going to be
completely Rewritten from scratch this
is coming from thedirect.com and they
say according to their sources writer
Beau demaio is leading Marvel studios's
efforts to overhaul the blade movie
starting from scratch and writing a
script that is essentially entirely new
they go on to say demaio's work as a
writer on Moon Knight and especially as
a head writer on X-Men 97 impressed
Kevin feige and other Studio Executives
leading them to hand over the reins to
him to rebuild Blade's story so this is
good news I can see how it could be
concerning to some people and if I
didn't hear the reports that mahershala
Ali thought the original script was bad
I would be pretty concerned as well
however since that script was reportedly
bad this is a good thing and hopefully
he Nails it with the script and blade
can be a killer movie like it should be
so let me know your thoughts on all of
this news in the comments down below
please like the video and of course
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU news for live updates you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof